Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. One of the things that bothers me
the most about the ignorance that pervades
our society is when people call in and they
criticize me for things I haven't set for
points I haven't actually made.
Criticize me for things I've said and do it
factually, and then we'll have a good conversation.
The San Antonio troll is someone who makes
a habit of this.
He calls in all the time, and he often will
criticize me for things I didn't say.
Sometimes it's things maybe from other shows
that he watched.
And in this case, he criticizes me for saying
India Walton would have won if she had been
more of a socialist.
I never said that.
I'm not a socialist.
I don't believe running as more of a socialist
would have helped her.
But that's still what I'm getting criticized
for.
Take a listen to this.
It's sad.
Speaker 5: Hackman, you know.
I just I'm sorry to call you and then you
know who this.
It's just you don't even have to play.
I just needed to get my voice to you.
I am.
My mind is blown listening to you, dude.
Like you would take with India.
Walton losing the buffalo.
No rice.
Your take is that these kids of socialism,
have she lost to a write in candidate like,
Hey, your take is all they need to be more
socialism, a micro?
Speaker 1: I never said that.
I never said that.
I don't even know where he could have gotten
it.
Did someone else say it?
I don't really watch other shows like mine,
but is there are one?
Did one of my colleagues say that India Walton
would have won if she had been more socialist?
It's just not my analysis.
Criticize me for things I've said.
Let's listen to a little bit more.
Speaker 5: It's time to like this.
I get it.
These opinions, like hating the father, hating
the flag, hating the family, hating the police,
hating capitalism
Speaker 1: must be taught.
It has to be talking about some other show,
right?
Speaker 5: Hating the big corporation.
I understand these are very popular opinions
on my Twitter, Reddit and Discord and YouTube
even.
But look, man, it just doesn't win elections.
The people are like, Hey, you know, I love
my family, you know, I don't want to
Speaker 1: go talk to someone who is actually
making these claims.
That would be my advice to the San Antonio
troll.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
There is one Republican senator ready to vote
to move forward with debating a major Democratic
voting rights bill.
And that's Lisa Murkowski, one Republican
senator.
We'll talk about that.
Number two, the American Psychological Association
is now apologizing for previously perpetuating
systemic racism.
What did they do?
We'll talk about it.
Is there apology substantial?
We will talk about it.
And lastly, Colorado hospitals are now in
a position where they may need to turn patients
away because of a resurgence in COVID cases,
and they are going to be allowed to do it.
We're going to talk about all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show, which you
can get instant access to by becoming a member
at Join Pacman dot com.
If you'd rather do the pledge via Patreon
that will also get you access to the bonus
show.
You can go to Patriot CNN.com Slash David
Pakman show producer Pat will join me.
Great bonus show.
Unidentified: Otherwise we will be back tomorrow
with another show.